European Parliament president Antonio  Tajani is to announce the winner of the  2017 lux film prize this annual award  celebrates the very best of European  cinema lawmakers are voting on an anti  dumping law that would protect EU  countries from dumped imports coming  from countries outside of the EU every  year over 25,000 people die on Europe's  roads members are calling to install new  mandatory driving assistance systems in  cars to bring that number down  Parliament is to discuss the paradise'  papers which have uncovered new  information on how the super-rich store  their wealth in offshore tax havens  corruption and the rule of law in Malta  are up for debate after the shocking  murder of journalist Daphne Kara Juana  Galicia in October